hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and i have
grave concerns about how well any of
these plans are going to go but let's
not worry about that
instead we'll get right into it because
i have a lot of thoughts to offload
let's go episode 106 and things are
drawing in as we had a bushy corporate
boy sneaking into the home bug base
he played a strong game at first getting
into the building and laying all those
exits it was frankly artful
i mean it was artful because it's an
anime but it was also like artful
how he did it without looking behind him
like how do you not okay look i have a
problem with people not looking behind
them
when they're trying to do something and
they don't want to be seen he did the
sneaky sneak thing dirty from being
covered in bush and looking back
i feel like the bushy infiltration was
the first step in the downhill slide of
nov and i should have taken the
simplicity of his perceived plan
as a sign that he could end up where he
was by the end
leaving trails in the dirt managing to
get onto the premises without anyone
around because there are no guards
the only way he managed to achieve
anything at all was because the ants
didn't care
they don't think he's worth the energy
and time of protecting against or i
guess the kid in the throne room is more
interesting
important and dangerous than anything at
all outside
after actively mocking the children from
running away
nov alone does the same like he says
he's not even actively touched by it
just sensing the strength of the guard
he he runs and and you know what he is
kind of cool because
that use of his new ability to just
dimensionally shift ahead i guess
that's pretty cool but he knows that
he's just not a match
for them how are they going to take down
whoever their guard is supposed to be
if nov is crying in a bush outside the
palace and how is that gonna work like
you know what just rather than me
speculating for the next five minutes
let's go back and look at some of the
concepts of this episode because it was
frankly beautiful
despite nov nov got inside the grounds
and sat beneath a tree a beautiful
white people tree and the image of him
looking up will stick with me for a
while
because at that moment the enormity of
what the ants have done what they've
been doing and the plan they're going to
carry out hit me
really hit me there's not been a point
thus far where more than a handful of
people have even tried to disobey the
ants
if humans have proven anything to them
it's that actually they'll walk into
their doom quite happily if they're told
to
i don't know if it was a direct call to
the song but in the translation
nov referred to a strange fruit there is
a hauntingly beautiful song
famously sung by billy holliday called
strange fruit but is essentially about
people who have been
lynched and again i'm not sure if it is
a direct call but oh boy is it relevant
in reverse those who did what they were
told became that fruit while those who
stepped out of
line or out of the norm were safe and
there are all sorts of ties my brain
wants to make to the cultural
implications of this and what the
storyline
overall shows when it talks about the
definition of socially acceptable
behaviors in different spaces that make
it easier for some to be manipulated or
for others to stand out or just to put
everyone in so much more danger than
should be possible and i got all of that
from a single image
of a man sitting beneath a tree of
strange fruit
while he considered how much worse it
could be if they'd done nothing and
while contemplating how many had already
been saved he sets an exit and i
wondered for the first time
what happens to nen when the nen wielder
dies i assume it fades away but does it
so few nen wielders have died so i don't
remember really thinking about it before
in any case the idea of an exit suggests
hope that things will go the way they
plan and
before we got into the building and nov
became hopeless or
hope lacking i guess there was a true
belief that the strange fruit here had
given their lives for a cause they
didn't know about they were the
sacrifice necessary to stop the ant
or the sacrifice necessary to help the
ants take over the world i'm actually
not sure which but here's the thing
though
if the ants take over the world they
would eventually farm humans wouldn't
they they need a source of food after
all so they would farm special humans i
imagine
and while i internally cringe at that
idea i internally cringe not because of
the
farming but at the implied loss of
freedom right technically every country
farms their people
people are encouraged to have children
and to do very specific things in
rearing them and engage a culture to
rear them as desired based on that
country's cultural perspective what's
the difference if it's anne
because really they're smart enough not
to over farm they're smart enough not to
just kill
every last source of food that doesn't
make sense what's the difference
ultimately between the guy who is
running the country and meruem
he's explicitly doing what was
implicitly being done and he hasn't
halted people like bisof but he also
didn't put bisdoff in place to begin
with and speaking of b's off i actively
cringed
at everything to do with that character
and that's interesting too right i
actively have a problem with his
behavior because it's nothing to do with
survival and everything to do with just
being
a really gross awful person if anything
he's the most disgusting creature i've
seen on this show and that's probably
because i've met
and seen and interacted with people like
him he's relatably off
i have a response to him a deep gut
response to him
unlike any other and i'm gonna stop
before we get any further because
hopefully palm can deal with him once
she's done her job and i hope she can do
her job because it seems like nov
actively cares about her which isn't
something i thought was real
i thought palm loved him from afar but
actually it maybe returned i'm not quite
sure what to do with that information
but he was reading the secret garden a
little while ago and
the amusement i now get from the thought
that maybe reading that book gave him
the idea to sneak in as a bush with tree
pockets
is just as good as the potential that he
was reading it because
i don't know he and palm share a book
club or something or maybe he thinks
she's unwell and he wants to find a way
to free her from it through
the magic of stories i'm not sure but
now i'm wondering so i'll continue to
ponder that while i despair at morel
thinking he's trapped lionel richie and
his ability copying
nen powers the level of hubris in the
idea that he's essentially contemplating
playing with his opponent before killing
him is just absurd and i really don't
expect it to go well so let's
move on to episode 107 and see just how
not
well it goes episode 107 and morel
didn't throw the fight but it says a lot
that he knew the person who owned the
ability lael used it means not only that
his friend is still alive but that his
friend made some kind of deal
with the the lion ant creature thing
camira come here ant
hey i wonder if that will come back to
bite them in the butt maybe not probably
not because it's the sort of thing
tagashi would leave open-ended but then
again
maybe the fight between morel and leo
was quite a beautiful one with a really
nice range of textures and colors and
i love the idea of the surfboard
and i'm not gonna lie actually really
not gonna lie a texture i felt was
missing was like you know a wet shirt
morel was underwater for most of this
fight but his pressed shirt stayed
pressed i mean i know it's fiction i do
i truly do but there's not enough starch
in the world for that also i feel like
that
yahoo from leon once he was on that
surfboard was so well earned that maybe
he deserves
or deserved to have that power more than
the guy it was taken from i could well
have believed that that particular power
was
actually his because from beginning to
end he's had surfer energy so i would
not have been surprised to find that it
was his naturally i understand the need
for combat to be broken up but i'm
constantly baffled by the idea that
people find
time and energy to big talk mid-fight
the whole i learned three things from
you
one i know what you can do two your
earphones are for show
luck or orders and three your life span
it just dropped
like this my morel then took things up a
notch confused the hell out of leo who
then
died we lost lael who has been with us
for quite some time talking a really big
game
they took me a moment to try to decide
how i feel about him dying and the
answer is actually yeah i did feel bad i
didn't cry
but it was kind of sad to see him die
and he made a good point about the fact
that his incapacitation of morel's
friend was
him defending himself his death took so
long that we had the time to engage with
his final thoughts and really
it gave us the chance to see that what
he cared about was
how impressive the power morel used was
and how much he wished he had it the
king of the jungle
savannah king of the savannah let's be
honest savannah king of the savannah's
last thoughts were about how he'd been
defeated
not pity not remorse or wishing he'd
done something different just an
observation
he didn't even consider that he was
dying beyond the vague thought that it
was happening which is very similar to
kilwa
in fact we're seeing a lot of almost
death and death thoughts coming up and
it makes me wonder what kite's last
thoughts were before his i'll say first
death and as we discuss death we moved
to palm who
encountered two kinds of energy the
first that was at distant
the other that found her and seeing that
she's not in the end credits i think
that's the end of palm we know that nov
is out palm was standing right next to
one of the exits right
next to it right on it she like she was
probably touching that exit i
she maybe she got away i feel of all the
characters
she drew the true short straw needing to
get to a point where she could see the
king
and failing that to kill herself rather
than let them get hold of her and yet
even if she manages to that's not a
problem for peter
but they don't know that so she went
through the entire situation of dealing
with bisof then got out went to do what
she needed to do and it's looking like
the only ones who can get close to
dealing with any of this are gone and
killer possibly not even killa not
properly though maybe he can now he was
compromised the last time
i hope palm survives but i doubt it and
that's sad and so we get tequila
who is back with octobuddy and so we
reached the point at which i did
actually cry this whole episode kind of
set me up really nicely for it
octo buddy's clothes are adorable but
that wasn't what made me cry what made
me cry was kilauea's growth and
understanding of friendship
and how it's supposed to work and the
fact that now he has his own character
to look up to him
both kids have found new friends on the
other side of the combat line and
there's a distinct sense of hope from
the younger ones that we couldn't have
from the older characters that the older
characters have shown such distinct
and obvious hubris while the younger
characters are just passionate about
fixing the situation is possibly the
only way they might win
with three days left until the fight
whatever fight that is with three days
left until the plan
there's a lot of things that seem to
have changed and none of these
characters are indispensable killua
knows this
and he explained it to octobuddy who is
so happy he could die
oh octobody please i'm worried because
octobuddy is deifying kilauea in a way
that i'm not sure is healthy but you
know none of this
is healthy where did kilwa learn this
dance anyway as someone who
had never had friends before gone did it
come from gone or is it his own thinking
that's led here either way the growth is
stupendous
and the combination of that and the
desperation octobuddy had to experience
that's what made me cry honestly there
are going to be more deaths
there is going to be an end point and
artistically it's interesting that kilwa
was framed by the same golden light that
he saw a few episodes ago
a light that surrounded natero even
earlier and it's a great metaphor for
death life strength as well as intense
danger and i'm here for it but i'm also
not here for it because that's it from
me
if you enjoyed this mind wander through
metaphor click here here and here
check out this probably thing like share
and subscribe and
i'll see you next time